quake is coming back in the form of
quake champions again we've been
promised isn't a MOBA but don't know all
that much about otherwise good news
right quake fans around the world
rejoice sure we're all old now and our
wrists don't work as good as they did in
the mid-90s but with all these
team-based class-based slot machine
shooters floating around it's nice to
have some straight-up no-nonsense arena
combats to look forward to I mean that
is if quake champions is an arena combat
game because the thing about the quake
series is that it's most defining
characteristic is how different each
game in the series is it's gone from
gothic Viking to future military from
multiplayer focus to single-player
campaign so come with me if you will on
a journey through the bargain basket of
steam a journey through two decades of
slipgates in the first-person shooter
genre this is the history of quake
Texas's ID's software I spent the early
90s defining the rules of the
first-person shooter genre 1992 is
Wolfenstein 3d wasn't the first ever fps
that was certainly the progenitor of
what we now recognize as the genre today
they followed it with perhaps the most
fondly regarded series in the genre the
timeless doom and doom 2 so in three
short years three of the most impactful
FPS games of all time came out of a
single studio so it's fair to say a lot
of eyes on whatever it was getting up to
next in the years preceding doom online
chat rooms and message boards were
bustling with rumors and speculation
around its next game what was their next
project what was it called what did it
look like and what genre was it the
origins of quake actually go back
further than that it's off forgotten 2d
platformer Commander Keen a series of
games we controlled a child on a pogo
stick
whose favorite hobby was to murder alien
wildlife and collect their tears now
what's up with these trees they look
like they're having a real
a promotion for the Keene trilogy made
reference to a follow-up game called
quake the fight for justice in which you
control the character known as quake
taken from a D&D game run by its lead
programmer and co-founder John Carmack
this character was said to be the
strongest person in the world capable of
transdimensional travel and wielding a
weapon known as the hammer of
Thunderbolts but this wasn't planned as
a shooter it was meant to be a 3d
role-playing game with complex
non-binary decisions on a realistic
immersive world after some prototyping
in 1992 it realized the technology to
realize their vision wasn't really
available yet and so the project was
shelved after they finished doomed to
the nine-person team including John and
Adrian Carmack John Romero Kevin cloud
and American McGee began working on a 3d
game engine the game that would
eventually help it to show off this
engine to the world took on many shapes
and forms during this time at one stage
it was a gothic Norse RPG at another
time it was said to have a VR tie in
with a major headset manufacturer
at another it was a local multiplayer
game with microphones using locational
audio so you'd have to whisper or else
the monsters would hear you hey lady be
careful there's a scrag behind you Jeff
but by the time this engine was finished
the team had been desperately working on
the technology for months on end so
instead of trying to reinvent the genre
again they took what they had created
and married it with what they knew
instead of the fantasy first person
action game they had envisaged quake got
doom style guns while a collaboration
with Nine Inch Nails frontman Trent
Reznor helped pulled together some of
the disparate design ideas that the team
had accumulated during development as
such the quake that was released in 1996
via cutest websites around the world is
a bizarre and unique looking game a dark
medieval style world filled with
unfamiliar technology and grotesque
creatures and it all worked surprisingly
well but then again I never wondered why
I was fighting Knights soldiers and
Lovecraftian ogres all at the same time
I never noticed how slipgates made all
the different worlds feel less
disjointed perhaps this was because I
was so taken aback by how different the
game played unlike doom it was an FPS
build with a mouse in mind Maslak
enabled the level designers to use
increased verticality while the game
didn't ignore height and depth like
first-person shooters before it you had
weapons with arcs there was increased
mobility in secrets and puzzles the game
also featured a wonderful multiplayer
component which proved popular across
college networks and online shooter
early adopters who learned how to shoot
rockets with lag kind of like world war
1 snipers it was also the first shooter
to get widespread mod support as we see
it today
with quake World Team Fortress and
action quake supporting large
communities four years after this gave
the game longevity past the length of
its campaign the quake fans would not
have to wait long for a full bonafide
sequel farewell speech as
the rest of humanity wish them luck
Godspeed quake 2 is an entirely
different beast to its predecessor and
the reason behind that is that this
wasn't actually meant to be a sequel for
quake the project known as strong and
Lock and Load in its early days was a
way for it to design a cohesive game
coming off the happy accidental mess of
the first quake by this stage John
Romero had left the company which meant
there was less internal interest in
keeping the Lovecraftian theme instead
1997's quake 2 was set on a fictional
futuristic earth and had you playing as
a marine named Bitterman fighting off
the invading strong forces theme aside
the game was relatively similar to the
first quake in that you fought off
hordes of varying enemies often in large
open arenas a number of weapons from the
first game also made the transition the
shotgun super shotgun grenade launcher
and rocket launcher were all here albeit
with a bit of a makeover at a personal
favorite the grenades which had the best
sound design and animation I have ever
seen in a first-person shooter this
quake 2 engine proved popular with other
developers and went on to power such PC
gaming classics as sin anachronox
soldier of fortune kingpin life of crime
half life and John Romero's daikatana
but the most enduring part of quake 2
for players was its fantastic
multiplayer quake 2 multiplayer was the
fastest game play online Shearer fans
had ever seen a masterful balance of
frenetic movements cool weaponry and
maps that acted as playgrounds for you
to sprint through guns blazing while
mods such as rocket arena action quake 2
and rail Wars made it the most popular
online shooter for years in fact quake
remained on challenge as the arena
shooter du jour for quite a while but as
broadband penetration increased more and
more people were playing more and more
games online while at the same time the
once spacious first person's honor was
becoming increasingly crowded from any
quake fans multiplayer had always been
the hook at the very least it was the
part of the game that kept before coming
back so in light of the changing face of
the genre and in an attempt to firmly
stunt themselves as the kings of arena
combat it decided to make their third
quake game a multiplayer only affair
you're tied for the lead and
quake 3 arena released in 1999 the same
week as Unreal Tournament was a
blissfully fast arena shooter featuring
powerful weaponry wonderful movement and
a variety of well designed maps as far
as I'm concerned this is still one of
the best online shooters ever made full
of timeless maps and modes from rail gun
battles on the longest yard rocket duels
on the campgrounds waiting for the quad
damage to spawn in the temple of
retribution you can also choose your own
skin from a range of characters who have
definitely lasted the test of time there
was meth biker creepy neighbor flanca
eyeball mohawk dude on a hoverboard a
selection of aliens made of triangles
and John Carmack it also looked
absolutely amazing for the day which is
just as well because I like many others
at the fork at 150 euro on a brand-new
OpenGL graphics card just to get the
game to work I mean look at that blood
look at the bubbles look at the blood
and the bubbles and though quake 1 & 2
were supplemented with popular map packs
quake 3 got its very own paid expansion
in quake 3 team arena an answer to the
increasingly popular team based modes in
games like counter-strike and Unreal
Tournament and the quake has been
traditionally a PC game even dreamcast
players were able to get in on the act
at least until a user created patch that
helped mousie keyboard using PC players
break into Dreamcast servers turn the
console crowd into lumps for the
slaughter quake 3 marks three for three
for the quake franchise each game did
something new and interesting and each
had its own unique style all these games
are still so well-regarded that if you
ask three quake fans which is their
favorite you could very easily get three
different answers the consistency of
quality coming out of it across the 90s
created one of the most enduring errors
in PC gaming and quake as much as doom
and Wolfenstein is to be credited with
this so let's talk about quake 4 all
right - maggots all ass or die quick 4
isn't a bad game but it does fall short
of the high-water mark set by its
timeless predecessors developed by Raven
Software while it was focusing on a doom
sequel the game was also built upon in
tech 4 and so looks a little bit like a
reskin of doom 3 it also played like it
too with a much more linear event focus
map design than its predecessors and a
hands-on approach to storytelling which
felt a little bit out of place in this
series that never really took it slower
all that seriously the one true sequel
in this franchise quake 4 carries on
directly from the events of quake 2 with
human brains invading the enemy's home
planet of straw boss or Stroh goes
frankly I don't give a [ __ ] but perhaps
the biggest fault of quake 4 was the
fact that the marketing for the game
telegraphed the big reveal in the story
that upon being captured your character
is converted like cutis of Borg style
into a strong this struggle ocation
scene is perhaps the most memorable part
of a game that attempted to emulate the
success of titles like half-life 2 halo
2 and doom 3 which had comment the year
prior quake 4 also had a multiplayer
with the spread of modes including
deathmatch team deathmatch CTF and dead
zone but the multiplayer of quake 4 felt
more like a requirement of a game
released in 2005 then something that
Raven had put actual passion into and
then we get on to the last quake game
Splash Damage the mod team turned game
design studio behind such games as quake
free fortress and Wolfenstein enemy
territory helped it craft the
multiplayer for June 3 their next
project saw them craft an enemy
territory style game in the quake
universe enemy territory quake Wars took
place before quake 2 and was a
class-based objective focused game with
infantry vehicles and air units I
remember enjoying my time with quake
Wars and generally have a lot of time
for the enemy territory template the
asymmetrical teams forced you to think
tactically while the objective based
nature of the battles focuses firefights
in a way that the battlefield series has
often lacked it was well received by
fans of that style of game but felt more
like an in-universe spin-off than a
bonafide quake game and that's sort of
how I feel quake champions might panic
this first new quake in 9 years looks
like it's going to be played in teams
using hero characters with unique
abilities and as popular as overwatch is
I do think there's room for an arena
team deathmatch game in this space this
is a tough one for it sticking to your
roots is a difficult balancing act
ignore the past completely you risk
alienating fans do it too much and you
end up with something like the Unreal
Tournament alpha everything I would have
wanted on paper but nothing to get
really excited about it's certainly
promising that perhaps the best sequel
to a classic game in recent
memory has come out of this studio but
if there's anything we can learn from
looking back at this story history of
the quake franchise its how each game in
this series was different to the last
the connective tissue that links these
classics together is the frenetic high
skill action that we've come to know and
love so I'm not too worried about quake
deviating from the template all that
much for me at least if quake champions
feels like a quake game that'll be
enough for me thanks for watching
GameSpot's history of quake if you
enjoyed this make sure you hit that
subscribe button because we've got a
bunch more of these coming over the next
couple of weeks and if you've got your
own story to tell about quake please hit
me up on Twitter or leave your thoughts
in the comment box below
you